really
[Music]
age awareness 3 is at its best when
you're locked in glorious battle from
flanking bonuses and line of sight to
magical research in the industrial
infrastructure of your empire every
detail in this turn-based strategy game
contributes towards making the
battlefield as complex and rewarding as
possible outside of combat the game's
managerial aspects are kept to a minimum
which keeps age of Wonders 3 moving at a
fast clip and frees you up to focus your
attention on the action each game of age
wanders 3 begins with you taking up the
mantle of a mighty hero such as an elven
sorcerer dwarven theocrats and guiding
your people through conflict to
prosperity before you can get in
conflict however you're going to need
cities to produce your army cities are
the backbone of your empire as well as
one of the game's main objectives
victory an age of Wonders 3 means
protecting your capital city while
defeating the enemies hero and capturing
his or her capital cities are largely
self-sufficient requiring little more
than your input on which buildings to
build your recommendations determine
which units the city can produce and
whether those units come with free
upgrades from specialized structures
once your army is on the field it's time
to explore your kingdom each of the
game's procedurally generated Maps comes
packed with treasure sites such as caves
or abandoned temples for you to stumble
upon these sites are usually protected
by packs of bandits or monsters both of
which are great for testing your newly
minted army upon before challenging one
of the game's main players
regardless of who or what you're
fighting your army is always gaining
experience and leveling up basic units
such as archers and Knights earn flat
bonuses to their stats as they move up
and rank while your hero units earn
skill points used to either increase
their stats or unlock special abilities
when you feel your army is ready or are
caught by a surprise attack it's time to
wage war when you engage another army in
battle you are transported to a more
intimate arena that's separate from the
world map the fighting takes place on a
hexed base grid which could contain
trees or boulders or even city walls in
the case of urban assaults using the
terrain your skills and every other tool
that your disposal is paramount to
victory rushing headlong into the fight
only gets you slaughtered woven between
the combat and empire building is the
research tree where you research new
spells and technologies for your people
it's one of your most powerful assets
but also one of the most unpredictable
as most of the trees randomized at the
start of the game depending on which
research options you have available your
strategy throughout the first half of a
match could vary wildly regardless of
the class or race you choose to lead
your rise to glory will likely begin in
one of the game's offline modes two
campaigns serve as a good introduction
to the game's mechanics as well as its
mythos while the scenario and randomize
map modes are great for just wailing on
the AI
[Music]
when you're ready to take the fight
online however you may experience some
hiccups on two different machines I
encountered connection errors with the
developer servers which prompted me to
seek aid through the developers website
and should you find yourself in a
similar circumstance and art already
well-versed in firewall port forwarding
you may find the developer solutions
woefully under developed online foibles
aside age wonders 3 is still a
well-crafted strategy game that doesn't
let itself get bogged down and needless
busy work some smart elements of
randomness help keep you on your toes
after multiple sessions though you may
find several go-to strategies still
apply regardless of the sort of army you
lead age of Wonders 3 is the welcome
return of a long absent strategy series
and a tactically rewarding game
[Applause]
[Music]